we know from our past experiences that  big things start small  uh you know the biggest oak starts from  an acorn and  you've got to recognize if you want to  do anything new  you've got to be willing to let that  acorn grow into a little sapling and  then finally into a small tree and maybe  one day  it'll be a big business on its own  and in fact that's one of the mottos for  one of your initiatives and forgive my  my pronunciation the latin but  greta team ferocity what does that mean  to you  well it means step by step ferociously  and it's the motto for blue origin  and basically you can't  skip steps you have to put one foot in  front of the other things take  time there are no shortcuts  and but but you want to do those steps  with you know passion and ferocity